okay here's the object I came up with we
can see that restoring name role in
context as well as welcome message and
skills as the keys in this object John
Doe is the value for name web developer
is the value for role notice how there
are commas after every value inside
contacts we're storing an object we know
it's an object because we see the curly
braces here and here inside this object
we have a few more keys and a few more
values for our contact information after
the object we have a comma then we have
our welcome message and then array for
our skills inside the array noted by
these square brackets we see four skills
then we finish up with biopic which is a
link to a URL with our image notice that
after this last value we don't have a
comma and then we finish up the object
with another curly brace